hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing five famous Southern
witches and wizards who went on to make
history within the Wizarding World
anyone referred to as simply a Slytherin
is a current or former student of
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry who assorted into Southern
house upon their arrival at the school
the house of Southern is representative
of one of the four founding members of
Hogwarts Salazar sutherin a powerful
wizard who believed in magical blood
Purity and argued that only pure blood
families should be offered enrollment at
the school as such many people associate
slytherins with cruel dark or simply
prejudiced witches or Wizards
unfortunately this view of Sutherlands
is further supported by the sheer number
of graduates who went on to become
entangled with dark magic but it's
important to note that that's not always
the case there are lots of good witches
Wizards who have been former Southern
students some of which we'll touch on in
today's video so with that in mind let's
take a look at five famous Southerns who
made history 5. the Bloody Baron today
the Bloody Baron is likely more well
known as The Apparition version of
himself the Slytherin ghost that
currently haunts the halls of Hogwarts
however the Bloody Baron whose real name
is unknown was once a student of the
school attending Hogwarts in the 11th
century promptly sorted into Slytherin
upon his arrival not much else is known
about The Baron's time as a pupil
however we do know that sometime after
he graduated he ended up falling madly
in love with Helen Ravenclaw the
daughter of another one of Hogwarts four
founding members Rowena Ravenclaw sadly
The Baron's love was an unrequited one
and Helena jealous of her mother's
accomplishments decided to steal
romina's diadem and run off to the
Albanian forests Rowena knowing of The
Baron's love for her daughter charged
him with locating Helena and bringing
her back home but upon finding Helena
she steadfastly refused to accompany him
back becoming infuriated by her
rejection he murdered her in a blind
rage stabbing her to death when he
realized what he had done he turned his
blade on himself and committed suicide
the blood that covers his ghostly self
is that of his own and helenas and is of
course what gives him his name the
Bloody Baron he is said to often roam
the Hogwarts astronomy Towers clanking
his chains as Penance for his sins 4.
Merlin another student of Hogwarts in
its more formative years the Harry
Potter version of Merlin was sorted into
Southern house upon his arrival at the
school and taught by Salazar Southern
himself it's rumored that Merlin had a
passion for ancient magic and studied
the secret rooms at Hogwarts that became
known as the cursed vaults as arguably
one of the most famous wizards of all
time Merlin was an advocate of muggle
rights and did not believe in the value
of blood Purity in recognition of his
contributions to the Wizarding World the
wizen gamut an ancient governing body
that predates the ministry of magic has
given out annual Awards known as the
order of Merlin of the first second and
third class since the 15th century the
first class order of Merlin is a gold
medal which hangs on a green ribbon said
to be a reflection of his house at
Hogwarts it is given out to witches and
wizards for acts of outstanding bravery
or distinction in Magic there was also a
stained glass window in Hogwarts History
of Magic classroom which features
Merlin's name and so well known as
Merlin and his accomplishments that his
name has even become part of the
Wizarding world's vernacular with
exclamation such as Merlin's beard heard
in everyday conversation 3. Phineas
nigellus black another famous Slytherin
although arguably much less so than our
first two wizards is Phineas nigellus
black Born Into the pure blood
supremacist House of black Dynasty
Phineas was a loyal believer in the idea
that mud Bloods and Muggles were of a
lower class than pure blood families
after graduating from Hogwarts veneers
later returned to the school to accept a
position as a professor despite not
being particularly fond of the role not
to mention the students he was supposed
to be educating he eventually also
accepted a promotion to Headmaster a
position which he was appointed to by
the ministry of magic it's here that he
made history as the school's least
favorite Headmaster of all time a title
that even his great-great-grandson
Sirius Black would later use to describe
him to a young Harry Potter due to his
lack of interest in actually being the
Headmaster of Hogwarts he was quite
oblivious to many of the dangers that
threatened the school during his tenure
particularly in the late 1800s one such
example of this is that he knew very
little about the goblin ranrock's
planned invasion of the school a plot
that was part of the 19th century Goblin
Rebellion against the wizard World 2.
Leta Lestrange a French British witch
who attended Hogwarts in the early 1900s
Lita Lestrange was a Slytherin pupil
whose closest friend was actually none
other than Hufflepuff student Newt
scamander the storied magic zoologist
and author of Fantastic Beasts and Where
to Find Them although Lita's behavior in
school resulted in a substantial amount
of trouble including the expulsion of
Newt scamander she went on to become a
respected employee the British Ministry
of Magic's Department of magical law
enforcement by 1927 Lita had become
engaged to newt's older brother Theseus
and later that same year in an effort to
stop Gaelic Grindelwald from killing
these Commander Brothers she sacrificed
herself and died incinerated by the
Flames from grindelwald's britego
diabolica spell it is said that Lita
sacrifice is what inspired Newt to
openly Challenge and go to war against
garlic Grindelwald alongside Albus
Dumbledore 1. Tom Riddle where where
Merlin is likely the most famous wizard
to have ever been sorted into Slytherin
Tom Riddle is without a doubt the most
infamous Southern in history born to an
impoverished marapi gaunt one of the
last surviving members of the once proud
House of gaunt Wizarding Dynasty Tom
Riddle was quickly abandoned by his
mother as a result Tom grew up in an
orphanage before entering Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry at the
age of 11. he of course was sorted into
Slytherin and spent much of his time
studying extracurricular material
regarding dark magic Tom was the student
responsible for reopening Salazar
slytherin's sealed Chamber of Secrets a
crime for which he later framed rubius
Hagrid upon leaving Hogwarts Tom went on
to become simply put a mass murderer
splitting his soul into multiple
fragments in order to create his
horcruxes which was his ill-fated
attempt to live forever it was during
this time that he amassed his loyal
following known as Death Eaters and took
on the monarch of Voldemort honorable
mentions while the previous witch and
wizards are my top picks for famous
Sutherlands who made Wizarding history
I'd like to give out a few honorable
mentions to other house graduates who
have also been mentioned in the history
books most notably there are a large
number of witches and wizards from the
house of black family who helped shape
the outcome of the Wizarding World
primarily during the 20th century for
example the three black sisters Narcissa
Bellatrix and Andromeda all played a
part in Voldemort's second Rise and Fall
to power of course the most famous of
the three would have to be Bellatrix
Lestrange rumored Mistress of the dark
lord himself and likely the most evil
witch of her time her contributions as a
loyal Death Eater in the first and
second Wizarding Wars more than well
documented Narcissa on the other hand
mother to Draco Malfoy is the witch
responsible for tricking Voldemort into
thinking that Harry Potter had died out
in the Forbidden Forest during the
Battle of Hogwarts she does this out of
love for her not Harry but had she
chosen to tell Voldemort that Harry was
alive things may have turned out a
little differently finally there's
Andromeda Tonks Andromeda is known as
one of the few members of the black
family to break ties with her relatives
due to her rejection of their beliefs
regarding blood Purity she married a
muggleborn Ted Tonks and they had their
only child nymphadora Tonks famed Aura
and member of the Order of the Phoenix
another member of the black family who
was a Southern and deserves an honorable
mention is regulus black Sirius Black's
younger brother regulus is the wizard
responsible for stealing and hiding one
of Voldemort's horcruxes in an effort to
prevent him from returning to power
finally I'd like to give recognition to
a few professors who also once belonged
to the house of setherin of course
there's Professor Severus Snape who
risked his life for years pretending to
be a loyal follower of Voldemort's in
order to avenge the death of the woman
he once loved Lily Potter Harry's mother
I'd like to to also mention the zany
Professor Horace Slughorn founder of the
slug Club who innocently shared
information about the Dark Art of
creating horcruxes with a young Tom
Riddle information which arguably set
right along the path to becoming Lord
Voldemort and then one last shout out
for Dolores Umbridge the sadistic
cat-loving former Southern who tortures
students and giggled while she did it
and with that we've come to the end of
another video what did you think are
there any other famous Sutherlands you
think deserve to be on this list please
share your thoughts in the comments
below and as always if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to like it and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
foreign
[Music]